an environmental epidemiologist who's
Pennsylvania home town was smothered by
a smog in 1948 that killed about 70
people when smoke ran like water is her
National Book Award nominated study into
the statistical causation between air
pollution and health ailments she spoke
about it recently for about an hour
tonight we're really excited to have our
author with us this evening the book is
really intriguing the book is when smoke
ran like water Deborah Davis is a
scholar in residence at the National
Academy of Sciences she's a former
scholar in residence at the National
Academy of Sciences and she is a
visiting professor of public policy at
Carnegie Mellon as well as a senior
advisor to the world health organization
would you all please help me in
welcoming Deborah Davis thank you all
for coming out on this slightly cool
evening for Washington DC I appreciate
it and what I'm going to do is start
with a song and I will tell you a little
bit about it while we just start to play
the song in a second when I was young
apparently I talked a lot about the town
I grew up in I'm going to tell you a bit
about that and this this fellow was then
a young man fascinated with the stories
I told about the huge smokestacks than
billowing clouds so he composed this
song his name is Philip Medlen he's now
actually a producer for Fox News in
another city and he's allowed me to use
it just at the context for what it was
like back in those days and we're going
to hear the beginning of the song and
then you'll see some archival photos
that I was able to obtain in the course
of conducting the research that we're
going to switch to one of the first
photo is going to show you what it was
like in Donora Pennsylvania in 1910 and
it's quite extraordinary because the
fact of the matter was people moved to
Donora Pennsylvania because of the
pollution that was there at the time
that because smoke meant money smoke
meant jobs
and there was no thought that it might
also be difficult for their health so
we'll go now to the slide you want it um
I think maybe I need to show you how to
do this again hold on a sec
this photo is remarkable on several
accounts one of which is it was made in
1910 if you take a look here you see you
look at the bottom of there you can see
that this is actually a small house this
is a huge complex even back then and
immigrants including my grandparents
were attracted to the town because this
meant jobs will just take you through a
couple more pictures here go page up
please oh this is a view of the mill at
three different times of day and you can
see how in the bottom you really weren't
able to see the mill at all when it was
fully firing and all the clouds were
there and that's just the way it was I
didn't know this is anything at all
unusual next this was a architectural II
quite interesting rendering of the mill
at the time when something quite unusual
happened there that I'll tell you about
in a moment this is the cemetery across
from the zinc works and it looks like
snow but it's not snow it's just that
they're nothing grew there there was no
grass in many parts of Jinora it was
great as a child because I could slide
down the hills i was a bit of a tomboy
we enjoyed that we didn't realize that
it might have had any consequences or
anything else the fact that grass or
trees couldn't grow there and the next
at one point some of the graves actually
washed out of the ground next children
were playing there in the background you
can see the smokestacks now if you hit
this sensor button on the south hero on
the keyboard hold on
this slide makes it clear to you why
Donora was a very interesting place in
terms of both steel and life you see
there it was inside a horseshoe bend on
the Monongahela River and the mill was
located right inside that bend and the
hills around the town weren't that tall
but they were just the right height so
that the hot fumes from the mill would
come up and the cold currents from the
hills would fall down and if there was
an inversion you got kind of a pancake
effect with the hot fumes normally would
rise as a hot air balloon Rises and
they'd come up against a layer of cold
that would smack them back down and if
there was a stationary mass of warm air
yet above it you got a kind of sandwich
effect which became a recipe for a
disaster now i have to tell you there's
i'm not going to read you a lot of
portions from the book cuz i think that
might be a little bit dull I invite you
to read my book when smoke round like
water yourself but i have to tell you a
story from it that i could tell at any
moment with great veracity because it
still is emblazoned in my brain I didn't
know there was anything unusual about
the place I grew up I really didn't and
what happened was like half of the town
my family left donora when the mill shut
down and I went to school at the
University of Pittsburgh I am a proud
product of the public schools of the
United States of America and the
University of Pittsburgh is where I went
to school because I didn't know there
were other options I came home one day
and I said to my mother mom was there
another town with the same name as ours
and she got kind of quiet and she's will
you know why you asking me said well I
read in a book at school that a town
with the same name as ours was polluted
so was there another Donora uh and she
got really kind of quiet she said well
you know you remember how we used to
drive with the lights on in the
afternoon and I was tall at a young age
remember how you used to get to clean
the walls down
what about once a month yeah she said I
guess today they might call it pollution
but back then it was just a living so I
I kind of I was just dumbfounded by this
and I said but they say people got
really sick and my mother said well your
grandfather used to say so long as the
mills were running the town was in
business when people would come to
Donora sometimes they'd say what's that
smell and if you lived there you said it
smells like money I knew that there was
something unusual about to Nora and I
went away in my work I've worked for the
United Nations World Health Organization
and at one point it went to a remote
area of China called shunji which was
famous for making leather for more than
800 years so they've got a fair amount
of pollution and they became rather
prosperous so they hit on a solution to
their pollution they moved the town away
from the pollution upstream of course
what what happened down streamed
everybody else was not of concern to
these people and I was brought in as one
of the experts to review this great
bustling new enterprise of Industry and
we understood that this was a very mixed
approach to a problem you know we'll
move away from the pollution and one
morning about five o'clock I woke up and
there was this huge explosion and fire
all over the place and smells of tar and
boiling batson I was pretty excited I
got my video camera and raised to the
window of this hotel room which was
still being built where we were staying
and I was really exhilarated and my
colleagues were embarrassed because it
was pretty dirty you know it was pretty
obviously heavily heavily polluted and I
realized I was excited because it
smelled like home and the things we're
familiar with are the things that we
want the things that are comforting to
us even if it turns out they're not
necessarily the best things for us this
idea of seeking comfort of seeking
normals
normal routine came home to me and
another time as well that I talk about
in the book I was in an earthquake in
Greece but I didn't know it because I
was in an elevator and I've been in
elevators that have been stuck before
but this one was a little different
because the elevator began to move
sideways and when it finally stopped and
I crawled out and got onto this marble
floor that began to move I realized this
was no ordinary stuck elevator and it
was something quite different and my
colleagues and I were at a conference on
environment and health and it was to be
the first scientific Congress where I
ever spoke about Donora Pennsylvania and
I I like everyone else that the Congress
was quite rattled by this experience but
all we wanted to do was to return to
normal so within two hours of the
earthquake which in fact left over a
hundred thousand homeless and caused
millions of dollars of damage we were
settled in a room listening to me give
my paper about de nora and i told the
story of what happened in Donora where
within 12 hours 18 people drop dead from
air pollution and i also told the story
of how my mother and my family never
talked about what had happened there i'm
just going to read you a passage from
the opening of the book to set something
of the context of what this story has
meant to me my Bobby fanny loved what we
western Pennsylvania neroli coasters
every year the entire family joined our
small towns annual expedition to
kennywood park near pittsburgh to ride
some of the best coasters in the country
now think about this the entire town
gets up and goes to an amusement park
and nobody Rob's or steals or any
nothing happens that's the kind of place
I grew up I love the thrill of sitting
securely next to my large soft
grandmother while being dragged slowly
upward and then whooshing down so fast
you simply had to scream to breathe once
when I was five as we staggered off the
famous
Jackrabbit with its double-dip drop
bubbie Fanny brought me over to greet
her cousin Sadie she said to Sadie
proudly in Yiddish this is my
granddaughter she's a little devil omit
a big mouth though Bobby had bragged
about my ability to speak I could not
Sadie had arrived a few months earlier
from Europe where everyone's relatives
seemed to come from and had been the
subject of conversations I barely
understood still flushed and breathless
from the ride I found myself facing a
strangely silent ghost-like woman I
don't remember if I even looked at her
face my eyes went to her forearm on her
freckled skin were some faded blue
numbers a bit deeper than the USDA
stamps on the meet my mother used to buy
from the butcher following my gaze my
grandmother said tell ur Saidi tell her
what this means I will never know what
Sadie felt then less than five years out
of the concentration camps standing
there amid the Calliope be music and the
screams of children like all those with
tattooed numbers on their bodies she was
immune from ever having to talk about
what she had lived through she said
nothing so as a child I thought the
whole process of numbering people and
counting was quite repugnant but people
never talked much about the Holocaust
when I was growing up and I only learned
later about its import and learned as
well of the importance of making each
person count no matter what happens to
them I tell the story in this book of
the remarkable survival survival of my
friend Deb fillers father saw she made a
one-woman performance show comedy out of
his survival he was one of 200 people to
survive marching from Auschwitz tutor
Asian stand out of 90,000 that started
he was one of the 200 survivors
and he talked with her about what that
meant and I will read you this passage
of when he and they they are taking a
whirlwind tour of European death camps
so that she can experience some of what
he went through at that time and there's
a guide going through the camps many of
you visited any of these camps it's a
quite an interesting they're they're
created like living museums at this
point and the guide was explaining to
the people she was taking through in a
very imperious fashion about 20,000 left
outwits to march here a lot of them
survived the Germans she said kept
meticulous records on everyone who ever
came here here was the torture chamber
much to the woman's surprise saw
objected excuse me excuse me that is not
true how could you say such a thing
nobody was fighting down the numbers I
came here from Auschwitz with only 200
he started with 90,000 they were eating
class along the way nobody was counting
the bodies for three days we sat in the
cell with no food bodies for all around
us if I had died here nobody would have
known so you see for me the Holocaust
was one of the great unmentioned shadows
over my childhood and the other frankly
was pollution I literally had to go away
from the town go away to school to learn
that there was anything unusual about
the place I grew up but I do know the
difference between the Holocaust and
pollution please understand that and I
do not equate them in any way except for
one thing they have in common they both
are subjects so grim and hard to stomach
that sometimes people prefer not to talk
about them at all and there is a
temptation at least among some to accept
the consequences of pollution as
necessary to submit more easily to the
evil of denying or lying about it and to
excuse those of us who would have us not
count
its effects so I wrote this book in
order to make sure that everybody counts
and I tell the story of what happened in
Donora and I tell other marvelous
experiences of growing up around
steelmaking which was a fascinating
thing to experience I described the
series of locks I'll read you one
passage here as barges would float
through the intricate system of locks as
the Monongahela was a river that moved
up and down the air the valley huge
metal gates would open the giant vessel
would slowly move inside as if being
swallowed by some gigantic whale and
then the gates would bellow with the
crunching creaking groaning sounds of
metal on metal as they majestically
swept shut the captain would tie up to
the side of a lock with oily blackened
Hauser's as thick as a leg crossing them
at bow and stern lockmaster and barge
captain would wave a thumbs up and
hundreds of thousands of gallons of
muddy river water would surge into the
lock then with a movement that never
cease to amaze us the ship would
gradually inch upward as though lifted
by some phantom force until it could
float out the other side and continue
its journey to the mills and coke ovens
anyone ever seen an old coke oven
battery they were all so fascinating a
commercial coking operation requires a
string of about 18 ovens called a
battery like a great shark that has to
keep moving to stay alive a coke battery
had to run all the time at temperatures
above 2,000 degrees Fahrenheit the ovens
had to be blocked shut to assure a
constant even temperature if they ever
cooled they could not be restarted
because the bricks crack below 800
degrees this meant once the oven was
fired hearty Souls with a good tolerance
for heat had to carefully stack bricks
together over the opening to keep the
temperatures up folks who work the ovens
tended to be young
now I'm going to change the pace a
little bit and read you a quote and ask
you who said it and when okay America
pays its debt to the past by reclaiming
the purity of its air its waters and our
living environment it is literally now
or never who said that when yes Richard
Nixon tunics you've read them Richard
Nixon said that on New Year's Day 1970
Richard Nixon was a brilliant politician
who understood the importance of the
environment and in my book I give him
his due we would not have all the major
environmental laws that we have now they
really owe a great debt to Richard Nixon
and many much progress we've made on the
environment really owes a lot to
Republican leadership and I say that
throughout my book in fact I also point
out that Nixon personally didn't really
care too much about the environment in
fact in the White House he'd like to
have a log burning in the summer because
he liked the homey feeling of it so he
turn up the air-conditioning to have a
log burning in the white house in the
summer in Washington DC but he certainly
understood what was happening nationally
and internationally on the issue of the
environment all right let's try another
that might be who said this our industry
has been back to the cliff edge of
desperation and time is running out as
far as the even tougher requirements are
concerned nothing seems to describe our
situation as well as that clincher by
Sam Goldwyn in two words impossible who
said it and when
you can guess what industry has been
back to the cliff edge of desperation
yes it was the auto industry and that
was a statement by Lee Iacocca a few
months before they made the miraculous
breakthrough of figuring out how to put
a catalytic converter on a car now let
me tell you a funny story about that as
some of you may be aware and I go into
this in some detail the early Clean Air
Act actually required that EPA set
standards for what would be coming out
of a car now it didn't set standards for
how the reduction in emissions would be
achieved just that it had to be achieved
and I go into some detail about the role
of goody night and Earl Warren from
California when Earl Warren was tapped
to become Chief Justice of the Supreme
Court good one night his deputy became
the acting governor and he be understood
that he had to take action on on air
they had protests that you'll see some
of let's go for a moment here keep going
I'm going to go through keep going keep
going
um
go ahead
go ahead
the keep going
that's a picture of Edmund muskie all
right looking at the the pollution in
New York skyline with Robert Wagner now
the reason Edmund muskie is very
important is that he was the chief rival
for Richard Nixon for the presidency on
the on the Democratic side and with the
push of Ralph Nader and others muskie
championed the environment as an issue
this is Richard Nixon signing the clean
air act on December thirty first
nineteen seventy and that's bill Rocco's
house the man who would later resign in
the midnight massacre that took a long
time to find and bill Ruckelshaus talked
about how the early days of EPA they
were like shooting ducks in a barrel in
terms of the way the industry took a
hard line position and they really did
not have much credibility in my book I
tell the following story there were
intense foreign rivalries and remember
we're recovering from the the Cold War
is still underway and companies like
Chrysler and Ford would come in and they
would say you know you're going to
destroy American industry and at one
point one Senate witness from GM
reportedly said okay sure they can
reduce pollution with those little
itty-bitty Japanese cars but not with a
real big American car well that slap did
not sit very well with so cheera Honda
and what he did is he took a Chevy
Impala back to Japan and he fitted it
with an existing cylinder head where he
put on it the pollution controls that
Japan had already developed and an epa
employee named Eric stork who's one of
the many unsung heroes of the
Environmental Protection Agency was over
in Japan and took the car for a test
drive and mr. stork told me that he came
back and gave the following speech to a
senior assembly of GM officials he told
the story about blue suit Burns who was
an Irishman with lots of friends who
spent a bit too much time in bars and
ended up
dying early and his wife who was quite
upset came into the Undertaker and was
quite distraught and The Undertaker had
arranged a private viewing for her and
there was blue suit burns in a brown
suit and she was very upset she said oh
my god what have you done I've he's
never been in a brown sue this this is
really terrible terrible The Undertaker
said oh I'm mrs. burns I'm really sorry
I think I can fix this so she went she
went away and she came back then for the
next day for the viewing again and there
he was in a blue suit and she said oh oh
I'm so grateful thank you so much I
really appreciate it he said wasn't
Jenny problem mrs. burns she says no no
I'm really grateful I'm just I was so
upset i'm sorry and he's it was really
no problem she said I I can't believe I
put you to all this trouble he said mrs.
burns it wasn't a problem at all all we
had to do was change heads and this
historic point was the changing the
heads of cylinders or company executives
is not always so easy and the early days
of the car industry there was a lot of
finger-pointing going opposite
directions and not much as
accountability now if you'll do page
down you go back please go back up now I
want to call your keep going quite a lot
till we get to the London I want to
point out that this what happened in
Donora Pennsylvania when people died
from air pollution was one more was
something that should have been a
warning to large cities in the world but
was not taken as 1 in science magazine
in 1950 a physician who had been
studying air pollution in the United
States for some time warned that the
real issue would be continuing exposure
to years of what he called non killing
pollution non killing exposure a very
strange term now we'll proceed and i
want to show you artists for years loved
painting london because it looked so
smoky in fact Monet
painted almost a hundred different
images of the smog in London he loved
its rich textures and I refer to that as
a source of inspiration for
Impressionism Dickens it was a foggy day
in london and fog was everywhere wrote
wonderful passages describing the gas
lights and the shops flaring and the Sun
with circled Eddie's of fog and how
above the fog there was this great black
clotted cloud this was the source of
inspiration for artists continued but
people didn't understand fully its
health impact until nineteen fifty two
exactly 50 years ago by the way this
time when in December in the beginning
of december there was a massive
inversion that settled over the entire
thames valley and although london is at
sea level m just a little bit below
because of the nature of the winds that
can come over the channel and because
london had a million chimneys when smoke
ran like water hence the title of my
book those million chimneys were pumping
out coal and it's pollution and the
fumes from those chimneys stayed in the
Thames Valley for a period of at least a
week and this is what it looked like at
noon at noon this is what it looked like
it was nighttime at Piccadilly Circus I
have stories of people getting lost
trying to get home during the London
smog one of the things we know happened
in London just before that smog hit was
that the town of London changed to
diesel buses and it may have been the
combination of the coal smoke which they
had for hundreds of years and the diesel
buses together that created this lethal
brew but what we do know next slide is
that in that short period of time
indicated there when the smoke was high
and the sulfur dioxide was high you see
the death rates leaped to four times the
normal rate normal being what it was in
the weeks before but what my colleague
Michelle Bell and I have shown in the
next slide keep going is that if you
look at the entire period
the three months of December January in
February the death rate remained
elevated and did not go back down to
normal for until the end of a
three-month period of time so we have
actually calculated and we report in the
book when smoke ran like water that the
true death toll of London's killer smog
50 years ago was actually twelve
thousand deaths more than normal now
that's an enormous toll for a short
period of time it leaves the larger
question of what this means overall
unresolved but in terms of calculations
we know the numbers are big and we know
while we are estimating them we know
that they are real and important now
we'll go through the next this is the
smog masks that they handed out that
didn't work at all designer smog masks
will go through the diesel buses Miriam
ders a hero of my book and I'm not going
to have time to talk about her in great
detail except to say that she did some
of the earliest work showing the dangers
of acid aerosols such as those produced
from these coal fired furnaces and
stoves she saw her own father died at
age 40 from lung cancer and he was not a
smoker but he worked in a coal plant and
when she did studies showing the hazards
of coal she ended up losing her job and
I talked in detail about what happened
how she was pressured by people who came
to discourage her from talking publicly
about her work remember this was in the
time of the McCarthy era and she was a
principal breadwinner of her family at
that time next this letter was found in
her possessions after her death by her
son and shared with me and it was
written to her by Alice Hamilton and she
saved it for more than 50 years in which
she said that you have to understand
that the man that fired you has wife and
children who are hostages to fortune so
there were pressures on scientists
working in this field even back then
next and this was an example of how one
industry responded to concerns about the
dangers of lead in gasoline they created
ethyl now
ethel tetraethyl lead was to represent
what was called Ethel gasoline and no
mention was made in any of the marketing
of the gasoline that it contained lead
which was known to be a potent brain
toxin at the time and people like Alice
Hamilton and Yandel Henderson and others
in public health warned do not put led
into gasoline you will be poisoning
millions and they were ignored and the
response of industry was to mount a
campaign to persuade people and you
can't see this here but what it says is
put me in your tank and get a kick
instead of a knock this is one of the
earliest uses of sex in advertising to
persuade people and you've course the
people buying cars at that time are
chiefly men and buying and driving them
and women were being used there to
market gasoline with lead in it to get
rid of the knock of the gasoline a
subject that it turns out that was not
the only way to deal with that problem
as well but the marketing and the
campaign that the lead industry carried
out for years is also documented in my
book ok we'll go on now just to make
clear that the problems we are talking
about are not all over the United States
now has made tremendous advances in its
environment but there are countries in
the world like Mexico that have more
progress to make and we still have
progress to make in the United States
and I'll go to the next to make it clear
that there is no such thing any longer
as a concept of just local pollution we
understand that toxic chemicals used in
the tropics may be banned in the United
States but show up in polar bears in
Wales in the Antarctic and that makes it
very clear that the planet as a whole
has to approach problems of pollution
and control the next this is the this is
a symbol of global warming you may not
be familiar with this is a 1,500 pound
male polar bear this photograph is used
with the permission of thomas d
mangelsen who is an award-winning
photographer and it shows a polar bear
trying to leap to an ice floe because
polar bears only can hunt from the
vantage point of being on the ice and
they wait for the seals or the walrus to
come up through a blowhole or to pounce
down on them because they're not as fast
as these smaller faster waterborne
animals of course well with global
warming consequences there is less and
less pack ice in the short summers in
the Arctic now more dens are collapsing
and killing some of the baby polar bears
earlier and the Bears are not doing too
well and obtaining food this is what
happens next a fabulous photo look at
the slide look at the shadow there on
the bear as its leaping to that flow
trying to get to a point where it can
get some food and of course you see it
doesn't make it and you can imagine the
amount of energy that's required for
such a bear I closed my book the next
slide with a description of the Defiant
inmate and I'll leave you with this when
I visited Dachau I found this little
statue off on the corner it's about life
size it's called the Defiant inmate
because in the camps men had to stand
with their heads bowed and covered at
all times their coats had to be buttoned
their hands could not be in their
pockets they were to stand at attention
with their feet together you can see
that this statue is doing nothing
unusual simply standing with head erect
coat unbuttoned and hands in the pocket
for that act this man could have been
killed and I say that sometimes the act
of doing environmental research is
nothing at all unusual but just doing
what is normal and yet the price that
people sometimes have been asked to pay
for doing such research is far beyond
what anyone should ever expect I end
with a story from Midrash that I will
share with you of a rabbi walking on a
beach at high tide and they're a bunch
of starfish stranded
and she's picking them up one at a time
and tossing them back into the water and
little boy walks up to her and says why
are you doing that it's not going to
make any difference and she says oh no
picks up a starfish made a difference to
that one and that's why I've written
this book thank you I think we have time
for a few questions or comments and tell
me your name please
and it wasn't fun
how do you feel about this policy
just putting a leadoff
the library
safe return preparers who
be back
right you're asking a question yes I was
nominated by President Clinton to be a
member of the National chemical safety
and hazard Investigation Board and
actually I was confirmed by the Senate
and officially appointed but I never
served in that capacity because it took
approximately four years to get budget
funding for that new executive branch
agency which was mandated under the 1990
Clean Air Act and didn't come into
existence I believe until 1994 and your
question is how do I feel about the
proposal that information about the
hazards of chemical plants are filed in
libraries and not easily accessible to
the public I think that we face a
challenge in our society today because
the threat of terrorism is different
than it has ever been and I I think
there are trade-offs right now that are
compromising some of our public health
and safety in the short term because of
these concerns and I'm afraid I'm not up
to date on what what the current issues
are here but I think that it's something
that we all recognize the need for
greater safety and for reducing our use
and the potential for exposure to
neighborhoods and workers of materials
that create dangerous it's clearly an a
very important problem that deserves all
of our attention yes in the back cool
how much base do you put in the bush
administration's
reliance on voluntary policing by
industry you know the problem with the
Bush administration is that they think
everybody's is nice as Laura Bush and
Laura Bush is a wonderful person let me
tell you something about the bushes home
that I talk about in my book their home
uses passive solar design it recycles
wastewater it uses natural heat from the
earth to heat the floor in the winter
and cool the house in the summer and it
is it is a green building and I was
fascinated to write to read about that
and I put it in my book cuz i think it's
an example of a civic virtue and of the
something that we should really applaud
and yet it is interesting that we don't
hear much about the bushes and their own
personal green efforts in their ranch at
crawford texas which was built so that
it could be more self-sufficient i am
deeply troubled by the environmental
policies of this administration and yet
i am a person of faith so I believe that
things will be better and I am very
encouraged by a number of large
businesses and innovative small
businesses that are stepping up to the
plate now and developing complimentary
forms of energy renewable forms of
energy and making large investments in
it the fact that you have large
companies donating hundreds of millions
of dollars now to research on
alternative energy is a welcome
development the government has to lead
but the private sector has a very
important job to play here as well and I
think that it's very easy to criticize
this administration but I'm I see some
good signs in the private sector and I'm
hoping that the administration will
acknowledge those and do the things that
it can to encourage that because we need
a massive commitment in the private
sector and the public sector to the
problems that we face today with respect
to global climate
thank you yeah this this looks like a
great book oh sorry my name is Bernardo
issam it looks like a great book and I
hope it is widely read I'd like to hover
express my reservations regarding your
enthusiasm for some of these companies
namely the Epistle powered light project
and green mountain energy headed up by
Sam Wiley now while I applaud the policy
of supporting renewable energy it's been
based on a free-market voluntary
purchase approach and critics have said
well this is like a boutique option for
the Sierra Club member or the
enlightened person who can afford to pay
extra and it was coupled with the gross
deregulation of the electric sector in
California supported by groups like
Environmental Defense Fund and NRDC
which have ties to utilities sectors
such as NRDC founder was ahead of
Southern California Edison which was the
billions in bailout from this and it
also benefited companies like Enron and
this has been a disaster environmentally
economically socially and just finished
mr. Wiley I think shows his true colors
when he took out the hit ads against
john mccain in New York these secret ads
that said McCain voted against clean air
and it was just preposterous think this
was a small amendment in a larger
picture but it hurt me King if you look
at mccain he's doing more on global
warming widely longtime supporter of
bush you know obviously does not cared
enough about the environment to support
green oriented and while you know i
would like to have a to i regret that
you know where's this broad enthusiasm
for green energy just as reflected by
this board for Enron all right thank you
I know thank is a very articulate
question you point out correctly that
there's a lot of paradoxes and
contradictions here with Sam Wiley who
is the was the founder Green Mountain
calm underwriting ads that actually help
to defeat McCain in New Hampshire at a
time when he was doing better than
george w bush and new york and uh III
can't dispute anything the facts you
have impressive you're obviously thought
about this issue for a while let me just
say this
I think that one always has to hope for
the best and prepare for the worst it's
an easier way to live life that's number
one number two in my book I talk about
the fact that there's one solution that
we have to accept if we're going to
solve this problem and that is we have
to pay more to burn carbon we have to
pay what it really costs this planet
that means the average American who
hurls two SUVs worth of carbon into the
atmosphere every year it should cost us
more but that if we simply made it cost
more money that would be unfair to poor
people and do those who work and have to
get around so we need to come up with a
system where there are rebates to people
who need some subsidies for their travel
and if we in fact every time you filled
your SUV it costs two hundred dollars a
tank I think we would see a very quick
shift away from some of these damaging
forms of travel and and heavily
polluting industries I don't dispute
that at all and I think the other thing
I'm encouraged by though markets are
imperfect and we certainly have social
support for big markets for big industry
no question about it but I happen to be
a c-span junkie and c-span is showing
now the State of the State addresses of
the governor's and I've watched several
of them and governor Pataki announced
that new york state is going to require
that twenty five percent of all of its
energy come from renewable sources and
the massachusetts governor romney
republican also has made a commitment to
alternative energy and Pataki and Romney
to newly re-elected or elected
republican governors have joined to file
suit against the federal EPA for its
failure to control dirty coal-fired
power plants so I think that in my view
politics here is has become almost
irrelevant to the environmental issue
because there's such broad public
support for action on on many fronts
that I think we're seeing more progress
and when someone like George Pataki can
make that kind of commitment I think the
next thing I'm expecting is to see em
the department of defense announced that
it's going to be using renewable energy
on its remote islands where in fact it
would make some sense to do that and uh
those are the things we need to
encourage and support and look for yes
sir max Friedman I work with the circle
of cases department justice and circle
was really badly written you might
explain you work on super fun related
photos working with the government
defense when the government gets sued
and the laws are really poorly written
at the federal level starting 1980 and
took about 15 years before smite woke up
and realized that they were totally
unrealistic especially with this big
fellow case without worked on but
there's a shift now is a once because
you talk about Pataki and Romney is that
the role of the states in controlling
pollution with realistic laws and
realistic approaches rather than running
and suing the government every time
something happened because I've done
cases in Pennsylvania had coal
facilities West Virginia a lot is at the
local level where the local government
or state government sometimes it's very
good sometimes is standoffish so I can't
say I blame the federal government for
everything because the states have their
own responsibilities that our own
constituents to work on and then if they
if it's it an overlap to a federal law
they should work with the federal
government rather than fight them so do
you see this as a state's responsibility
as well as a federal responsibility well
you know we have an imperfect government
it's called a democracy it's not it's
got a different kinds of representation
the some of the most populous states are
represented by 18 senators and the rest
of the country is represented by where
there are like in the state where I vote
Wyoming there are fewer people than
there are in Washington DC so with
understanding that that's the system
that we have I think that some large
states are capable of handling these
issues but I'm deeply troubled by what's
going on now because of the radical cuts
in federal funding let me just give you
one example in California this week they
announced that they will abolish the
state's capacity to assess risks of
pesticides abolish the entire program to
do that in California which as I think
some of you know California would
qualify to be like the eighth largest
country in the world if it were a
separate country and it is a state in
which i think more pesticides are used
for some forms of agriculture than any
other state and the state of california
with its democratic governor has justin
made an announcement to abolish totally
the capacity of the state to assess the
risks of pesticides so i'm very
concerned if you start to give this
authority to the states whether it's for
toxic waste such as the Superfund law
covers or pesticides in the workplace
and you are simultaneously taking funds
away from them that they would otherwise
have from the federal government i think
that's really not fair and not just
because those who are going to suffer
the most will be the ones who are on the
front line of the workers and their
children who we know are at greatest
risk so while it is certainly true that
where states have the capacity and some
of the larger states have had the
intellectual and the resource capacity
to address these issues i think that's
wonderful but for states that are poor
an alabama we just saw the new york
times recovered
coverage of what happened there with the
complete abrogation of enforcement of
workplace safety and health of a the
pipe fitting company mcvane that was
discussed in a three-part documentary
The New York Times and also on a
frontline series on PBS those kinds of
problems I think we're going to get
worse given the current economic climate
because we're basically pulling the rug
out from under the states by cutting
federal funds and not giving them any
recourse or resources to draw upon Dan
or Bush reachable
and she wakes up one morning and she
says you know George I really like this
definitely
I think she she could go and do
something great for our
why don't you just give her about 50
billion dollars maybe put a penthouse on
top of the reagan building and
the energy czar over and above
everything else and spend that 50
billion dollars they call you on the
phone as they ever come on down how
would you do it well I'm so glad you
asked I'd start with job training we
have we have in this country under
educated under trained people whose jobs
have been replaced people who have
become dysfunctional in our society
because we've moved so quickly to the
high-tech end of the world and there are
many things that simply take labor to do
and to do well that involve rebuilding
the infrastructure of our schools and
our communities creating for example
public transport that works creating
meaningful trails and rails and bike
paths and things like that that would be
a work a work program for those who are
underemployed and a way to create a
structure for our society where people
would be able to be healthy in the work
and create a healthy environment around
themselves frankly dan you could
understand I need to think a little bit
about that but I certainly know we need
to do that there's enormous opportunity
there's enormous potential our country
still has the greatest potential it
still is a great country and I wrote
this book criticizing some dreadful
things that have happened in the past
for which people should be ashamed but
I'm also encouraged by the fact that we
still have the spirit to get it right
and and to improve and i hope this book
will reach people like mr. and mrs. Bush
and others because I think that we can
there's no question we can do better and
there's no question we need a major
commitment to education and training for
people who have been left behind it's
not the just the children who are left
behind nowadays thanks
yes Alan Alan load I have a similarly
open question and that is
what factors in society or economically
do you think brought us to this approach
that caused the pollution problem what
is it that made people behave in that
way well you know I I don't know if I'm
smart enough to answer the question of
what brought us to this to the situation
but I think part of it has to do with
what a sociologist Max Faber would call
the Protestant ethic and the spirit of
capitalism and the notion that if you
were really a good Protestant you worked
hard and if you worked hard you
accumulated capital and so you being
rich was a sign of your being a good
Christian person under the Protestant
ethic and that translated into focusing
on the profit motive and the
accumulation of stuff at the sacrifice
of a lot of other things and having a
longer term future orientation is
something that is maybe antithetical to
certain economic thinking and I'm sure
you've heard Cain said in the long run
we'll all be dead and so therefore the
long run was not of great interest to
economics and I think that way of
thinking is anathema to people like me
in public health because we want there
to be a long run we want to make sure
there is one we want to make sure that
the planet is able to survive we want to
make sure that our grandchildren will
live in a world where they'll be able to
drink water from certain streams which
they can't do readily even right now so
i think the perspective of the near term
the short term the bottom line which is
understandable when your industrial
izing a society created this problem of
not looking for the longer-term
consequences of activities
alright well I want I want to thank I
want to thank you all and I want to say
that this has been an amazing experience
I want to close by reading of short
thing from the funeral of Bella Abzug
and I want to explain to you that I was
privileged to know Bella in the last
year's of her life she was a pretty
spunky lady and I I guess I'll tell you
how I first met her this I talked about
in the in the book as well I got one of
those phone calls you know Sunday
morning it's like about eight o'clock in
the morning the phone rings and you
immediately think uh oh it's bad news or
it's a wrong number right well it wasn't
it was it was Bella and she was on the
phone and she said this is Bella my
friends are dropping like flies I'm
going to have a hearing at City Hall and
I want you to be there now I never met
her and he and but that was Bella this
is Bella and I knew from the voice who
she was and of course I showed up of
course and she began to harangue me
about why we didn't know more about this
and what was going on because she had so
many friends they were dropping like
flies and she we had to figure this one
out and she explained to me what she had
done for nuclear disarmament that as
soon as they had figured out that
strontium-90 got into milk as soon as
they were able to tell mothers that
their children's milk was contaminated
with radiation that was it so she said
well you got to find the milk here and I
said you know Bella it's not that simple
and I had quite a number of interesting
experiences with her including being
with her in Beijing at the International
Women's Conference and pushing her
around in a wheelchair and at the time
George Bush the former president gave us
talk in Japan and made a quip that he
felt sorry for the Chinese having Bella
Abzug run around there of course she was
in a wheelchair so that was kind of an
ironic thing he might not have known
that and she then replied with her own
retort
uh pointing out as she said well he was
speaking to a fertilizer convention
wasn't he uh so she was a she was
definitely a force of nature but in the
end of her life she was really affected
with congestive heart failure and
arthritis and she had breast cancer and
we would have conversations about
whether there was anything after death
and what meanings of what would go on
after we left this earth and I assured
her that I believed in an eternal life
and she said yeah what makes you so sure
that I said you know I can't prove it to
you it's something that I I know I
believe with all my being and then I
said to her you know what makes you so
strong in the face of all this pain why
don't you just go to Florida and play
mahjong if you don't think there's
anything after all this and she said
well I guess I know my mother is still
very proud of me and I said you know I'm
sure we're all going to be connected in
ways through our work and her funeral
was a really a bit of a blast and their
young woman rabbi got up to begin the
funeral and said if Heaven ever were
male dominated she looked upward and
paused for that to sink in we know
things are changing right now and that
brought down the house and then Shirley
MacLaine who is known for her efforts to
communicate across time and space with
those long gone from the earth began her
remarks looking directly at the coffin
and said I of course will speak directly
to Bella and she turned to address the
casket to her left and continued Bella
you always said you were a feminist but
I also know you were basically a You Man
'used McClain stressed the middle
syllable at that moment the microphone
which stood several feet from McClain
and well away from any living soul
fell off its stand the crowd gasped ok
ok Bella I was just kidding McLain
replied Thank You Deborah Davis is a
senior advisor to the World Health
Organization when smoke ran like water
is published by basic books on the web
at basic books calm